first productivity tip I want to talk  about is time boxing time boxing means  that you look at your calendar you plan  your week or your month ahead and your  schedule some time into your calendar  for things that you really would like to  accomplish and I feel like this is  especially effective for things that are  outside of your regular work of course  in your regular work you know that you  will need to make the time for the  things that really matter but what is  everything that comes on top of that  maybe you have some side projects that  you want to work on maybe you have an  exercise routine that you want to  prioritize make sure that you block off  this time in the calendar and then be  realistic you'll even have enough time  in the evenings on the weekends to get  this done make sure to prioritize  accordingly to get this right